[موسيقى]
تاتي يعني فكره المصلى الدعوي المتنقل في
اطار يعني تطوير الوسائل الدعويه
لاداء الصلاه جماعه طبعا كانت الحصائر
تفرش في هذا الكورنيش الذي يعج ويضج
بالمصطافين لا توجد مساجد قريبه صراحه على
عند المصطافين وبالتالي للحفاظ على اداء
صلاه الجماعه على وقتها كانت فكره هذه
المصليات وتم تطويرها لتكون فكره المصلى
المتنقل حتى يؤدي المصطافون صلاه الجماعه
على وقتها
[موسيقى]
فكره المصلى المتنقل فكره ابداعيه قامت
فيها وزاره الاوقاف بالتعاون مع مجموعه من
المحتسبين الموجودين في المكان هذا وهذا
فضل الله سبحانه وتعالى علينا انه انا
اكون قريب من اهلي ومن اولادي ومن زوجتي
اولادي بكونوا حواليا باجي بقدر اصلي ربما
قطعه الشارع راح تكون صعبه شويه فسبحان
الله هذه قربت لنا وعانتنا على قيامنا
بعبادتنا وصلاتنا وقيامنا على فرض ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى
[موسيقى]
اهل قطاع غزه اجمالا معروفين بانهم يعني
مجتمع محافظ وبالتالي
يحافظون على الصلاه على وقتها وهذا طبعا
المصلى ساعد وعزز في اداء المصلين لاداء
الصلاه على وقتها وسبحان الله ما ان يؤذن
المؤذن للصلاه نجد انه المصلى يمتلئ عن
بكره ابيه ولو كانت الحصائر يعني فيها
متسع اكثر لراينا ايضا مصلين اكثر اضافه
لانه يوجد مكان خاص بالنساء في المنطقه
السفليه
[موسيقى]